اا بدايه خلينا نرجع لتاريخ الكره القدم
كره القدم وجدت اصلا في الثقافات القديمه
جدا يعني في الثقافه الفرعونيه في الثقافه
في الثقافه الصينيه وما الى ذلك
بمفهومها البسيط لكن مع ال التقدم والتطور
يعني توارث
اللعبه اصبحت ااه جزء من الثقافه همم وعاء
الثقافه يحتوي على جوانب كثيره من اهمها
ان هناك ثقافه مرتبطه او ثقافه هامشيه
مرتبطه بالالعاب والالعاب الشعبيه وما الى
ذلك تحول لعبه كره القدم الى ان تصبح من
مجرد هوايه جسديه الى ثقافه او جزء من
ثقافه المجتمع اصبح لها هذا الدور لو
قعدنا ما هي العوامل اللي جعلت من هذه
الثقافه مهمه لدى مثلا جميع المجتمعات في
العالم خصوصا في هذا الوقت ح ان هي مرتبطه
بتنشئه الاجتماعيه مرتبطه بالطفوله مرتبطه
بذره بذاكره المكان والزمان بمعنى انه
دائما نحن الى ايام الطفوله كيف احنا نلعب
كره القدم مع اصدقائنا في ال- في المدرسه
وما الى ذلك فحتى اطفالنا من اول ما ينشا
اللي همم الذكور
نجد اهتمام بكره القدم
السيارات بين النساء بالعاب اخرى هذه كلها
همم تجعل همم يعني همم لعبه كره القدم
شغف خاصه الشعوب ايضا هي مرتبطه بالعمليات
الاجتماعيه احنا لو جئنا نتكلم عن المجتمع
هنلاقي المجتمع همم داخل همم عمليات
اجتماعيه تكون او تنسج او تحيك نسيج
الاجتماعي في اي مجتمع فنجد مثلا عمليات
الاجتماعيه مثل التنافس وهي جزء من
الطبيعه البشريه نجد ايضا همم غير التنافس
لنجاه التعاون
التكيف وهذي كلها اشياء تؤثر على ال- همم
للشغف ايضا هي مرتبطه باحلامنا وتوقعاتنا
همم الفوز والشعارات اللي احنا نستخدمها
اغاني الاهازيج اللي احنا نستخدمها في امم
التعبير عن الحب كره القدم ايضا هي تحولت
مع الزمان الى مشروع تنموي همم انساني همم
لانه انشاء مثل هذه الاتحادات وما الى ذلك
تدفعها اشياء كثيره اخرى همم جزء منها عمل
اعمالك بشكل عام همم العمل همم تخفيض
البطاله